whether you're a blue shell buff or a
Nintendo novice Mario Kart is one of the
few games that's really permeated
popular culture so given that it's been
six long years since Mario Kart has hit
the track on a home console this is
something of a momentous occasion
so here's everything you need to know
about Mario Kart 8 one of the most
unique and interesting additions in
Mario Kart 8 is the feature of
anti-gravity racing as you'd expect this
results in you driving up walls and
ceilings without the frustrating
consequences that usually come from
obeying the laws of gravity while
sipping about in anti-gravity mode if
you bump into another racer your Kart
spins and you both get a speed boost
even if you are a Mario Kart pro you're
still gonna want to know about Mario
Kart 8 for new items and how they're
gonna help or hurt you on the track set
items include the boomerang which can be
thrown three times and can attack racers
on its return flight so just like every
other boomerang in any game ever then
there's also the piranha plant which is
the same mario pipe dwelling dude that
swallows you up when you're not paying
attention but here he attacks nearby
races and gobbles up obstacles and coins
then there's the crazy eight which gives
you access to eight of the most popular
power-ups all at once and is
particularly useful if you're lagging
behind in last place the final and
potentially most life-saving item is the
super horn which has the ability to
deflect attacks and might finally bring
an end to the blue shell bastards reign
of terror Mario karts new editions don't
stop at tracks or items though it's also
worth checking out the new online modes
add a basic level you can play with up
to 12 competitors online and players are
able to set up tournaments with whatever
rules and schedules they like they'll
also be able to download ghost data from
their friends or top players from around
the world to see how they stack up Mario
Kart TV will feature replay data from
other races and players can upload their
own runs to move us or their highlights
to YouTube
and the final thing you really should
know about Mario Kart 8 is probably
something you've already noticed by now
the game looks freaking gorgeous
technically the game is set to run at 60
frames per second in single-player but
no matter which way you spin it the
thing looks really cool especially if
like me the last time you really took
notice of a Mario Kart game it was on
the n64 from electro dome to sunshine
Airport all the tracks are
environmentally varied and graphically
impressive and the animations are
totally satisfying which makes getting
to the head of the pack all the better
hola Mario Kart 8 is looking pretty damn
cool and even though personally it gives
me the birdie
rayji feelings at least it's got some
awesome new tracks great vehicles and
exciting new items to get those vibes of
nostalgia burning again last week I
talked to you guys about steam machines
and tried to help you find the right one
for you and you had an awful lot of
opinions many of those opinions revolved
around whether the systems will
worthwhile at all y'all Borland that who
does the steam machine appeal to exactly
people that care about PC gaming either
already have a PC or choose to build one
people that do not care buy consoles in
response a d / dime instead it's to
bridge the gap between PCs and consoles
aka getting console players to become PC
gamers as for those of you thinking
about spending some money on one of
these pick a link 91 said I will never
replace my consoles but I will need a
steam machine to make up for my laptop's
lack of power let me know in that
commenting section down below how you
feel about last week's topic of this
week and whether or not you're gonna
pick up Mario Kart 8 I will see you
again next week